haben sie denn konkretes datum im kopf
verbrauch wo sie sagen okay dann wird
los geimpft in deutschland das wird der
tag sein oder die woche seien also das
hängt jetzt natürlich von diesen
unabhängigen gremien ab aber ich rechne
damit dass das ganz früh im nächsten
jahr in den aller ersten tagen losgehen
kann
und am anfang wird es auch noch gar
nicht so kompliziert sein weil
vermutlich erstmal auf das
gesundheitswesen leute die direkt mit
patienten zu tun haben und so geimpft
werden sollen
dafür müssen alle anderen noch einen
moment zurück stehen richtig logistisch
aufwändige und spannend wird es wenn wir
hoffentlich im frühsommer so viel
impfstoff haben dass wir wirklich breite
teile der bevölkerung impfen können und
dann wird es eine logistische
herausforderung